[Music]
[Applause]
okay so Dame Lillard an interview that I
did yesterday and we got him he's in his
car and uh
he's being shut down for the rest of the
season and I you know he you know what
he does an interview at least one once
every year and he's always good and I
wanted to talk to him about a variety of
things and I started out by saying
nobody plays defense in the NBA anymore
right
I mean that seems to be a popular thing
to say and then you get out there and
it'll be hard for a lot of people to get
something done
do you think I could score on Luca
uh
probably not okay but the fact that you
gave it some thought because you know
Luca doesn't play defense so I'm going
to take that as a company depend on how
much effort he was won
you're listed as a point guard aren't
you
yeah
but you're a shooting guard
no I'm a point guard
why do we even have designations
why don't we like first team second Team
all NBA I said to the commissioner why
do you have to have a center on there
why not the five best players because
there's a lot of money attached to
making first second third team why are
we still doing that I definitely think
it should be the best five players not
by position
I agree with that
well help me out here I mean I'm trying
to lead the charge here so we can have
the five best players I mean look Rudy
gobert's a nice player he shouldn't be
first team all NBA or second Team all
NBA because he plays center
yeah I mean I think it's like you said
it's one of those things because it's
um position based you end up having to
plug somebody in there even if they're
not actually yeah uh performing at that
level and then somebody that is might
end up missing out on it so please
definitely think it should be the five
best how much basketball do you watch
when you're not playing
I watch a lot you know I'm usually
especially on the west coast I'm usually
you know trying to make it home for that
first Eastern Conference game and start
at four o'clock here
even if it's you know two teams that
aren't you know in the running for
anything I'll still go and watch the
game you know I think that's why I'm
familiar with a lot of players you know
I just know you know just from watching
so many games I watch I watch every game
if I could
who's your MVP this year
uh Joe lmb
why
I picked Joe lnb because he's you know I
feel like he's been dominant
all season long
uh his team is winning I feel like he
could have won it
uh one of the last two years but I think
yoga's won it both times
and I just think because he's been to me
the most dominant player
um you know he's been carrying his team
I think you can't you have you can't
continue to give it to a guy who's won
it twice in a row
and especially when you have a guy like
this that's performing at the same level
or maybe even higher and he also you
know
didn't get it you know one of the last
two times when he was at that level I
just think that you know that's not how
it should work
and you could give it to Giannis again
this year yeah you could the one thing
is that I feel like like I would
choosing bead over both guys is because
where Giannis as great as he is
you know he won his the one knows
back-to-back MVPs and that doesn't mean
he should be able to Win It Again
but
um when you look at the depth of that of
their team like they just so deep you
know you're there they're gonna win a
lot of games you know you got guys like
Drew holiday and Chris Middleton and
Brook Lopez
Joe Ingles I mean they so deep
uh
Bobby Portis they they so deep that
they're going to win games and that
doesn't take the credit away from how
great Giannis is
but
I just feel like you know
the the team success factor is going to
be played in so you also have to
consider just how how good that team
actually is you know so
um
this year I would just I would give it
to him beat I think it's his I think
it's his turn
somebody gonna get 90 points in a game
I don't know when but I can see it
happening for sure who would be your
pick
I would either pick myself or I'll pick
Steph Curry
see I wondered about clay
being a guy or
Booker well I mean these guys have had
60. 70. you're there what would it take
I think they're I think they're capable
of doing it you know book or or I think
clay would have a harder time because
clay doesn't get to the free-throw line
okay
yeah cause you're gonna have to shoot
about 20 free throws at least
I mean you're gonna need some you're
gonna need to shoot a significant amount
and I just don't think he shoots enough
free throws
um
you know he would I mean he could make a
lot of Threes I'm sure clay could get
really really hot for three and make a
lot of Threes but
I mean if you think about it you can
make 23s and you still 30 points away so
I mean you're gonna need to get to that
line you're gonna need to get to the rim
a little bit
I mean so I would say Steph I could see
book I could see book possibly doing it
as well is your season over
uh most likely
your decision
um I mean I wouldn't say it's my
decision at all I think uh
maybe the team protected Me From Myself
um you know we've had so much
we've had so many injuries on our team
you know not just right now but
throughout the season you got guys
who've been banged up that
just aren't healthy enough to go out
there and make a run for it right now
and
um with me having a few uh injuries this
season with my calf none serious
and then my you know happened to play so
many minutes down the stretch because of
those injuries that we have now
Cavs started to tighten back up on me
um not in a way like you know something
crazy but just tighten up to where
there's almost precautionary you know
because there is something there and it
is tight I took my ankle so it's just
like you don't want to be
overcompensating and they know I'm gonna
go out there and compete and I'm gonna
try to make it happen every time that
I've that I've had some type of injury
like that kind of get get irritated or
aggravated or something like that
um it's come from just like a heavy load
and stress and just you know going out
there and trying to
to go above and beyond so you know I
would say just there is something there
and also them trying to just protect me
from protect me from myself as well why
is loyalty sometimes viewed in a
negative light
I think because it's something that
um if you're not the person involved if
you're not the person
uh who's living whatever that loyalty is
to or whatever that's about then it's
hard to understand and I think
a lot of people look at my situation and
they're like man they ain't being loyal
and Loyalists and loyal to that and they
just kind of throw it around
and I've explained it you know I'm not
trying to get nobody no loyalty
um I don't know I ain't trying to give
no loyalty speech and all that stuff but
that seems to be the way it always gets
flipped
because I get asked about you know my
situation but for me
I just have I just have a way that I
want to get things done for myself you
know um
that doesn't mean that the things could
never change you know the team could one
day just be like look
we want to see that happen too but it's
not it's not working out we don't know
you know I don't you know I never you
never know yeah
um I just have my stance on what I want
to see happen but I mean in this in this
business you just never know man but I
always go back to kg kg would be
criticized in Minnesota because he was
loyal and I said it feels like whenever
somebody leaves then you're chasing a
ring and like you're damned if you do
damned if you don't well everybody stays
in the ring that's what we play for you
know what I mean
but it's like when guys leave a team to
go to another team it's like oh he's
just chasing rings
and I think how it ends up looking that
way is because
you move on you move into a situation
and that situation just might not work
out
so when it's not working out you know
maybe the team is having respect for
these guys because of you know what
they've accomplished and who they are so
they're saying you know okay this ain't
working out here what do you want to you
know let's work together
and they're gonna try to find the next
best situation that suits them and where
they could possibly win so now it's this
guy's chasing rings
so
um
you know I think you damned if you do
them if you don't yeah you know when
things change
uh whether that's in my control or not
in my control then you know I'll move
from there but right now
um
you know people are like man it's time
to do this it's time to do that but
everybody does that has something to say
they will never have to wake up and be
Dame Lillard you know they just they'll
never have to walk walk the walk for me
I'll always be the person that has to
deal with
whatever the pros and cons of my
decisions are so I can't
you know I can't do things based on what
what other people think or whatever the
criticism or whatever the chatter is I
gotta I gotta continue to do me you know
yeah you know like I said if if you're
leaving it you know or you don't leave
them to go well why didn't you want to
chase a ring and then if you stay why
you know that's why I always don't want
to win he just wanted to make money yeah
he just this he just that but you know
really they don't know it's just
maybe it's just how they how they feel
about themselves if they were in that
position and they made the decision I
made that means this is what I wanted
but really they don't know so
I gotta take it with a grain of salt
keep fighting a good fight good luck in
the off season always great to uh to
talk to you Dan thank you thank you
appreciate it man good to see you Dame
Lillard